فقرات يعني تغذيه على صحه انت عامل الكيتو
دايت الكيتو قبل هيك شوفي ما كثر ما سمعته
بس تاكلين لحم تاكلين لحم انا عندي مشكله
يقولون احنا يقولون عند ربعنا مقابله
للعيش ولا مقابل الجيش ولا مقابل العيش
بمعنى تواجهين جيشا كاملا ولا تدخلين في
صراع مع طبق رز فبالتالي انا انا احب الرز
ما اقدر
بدون رز اصلا
يقال بالاردن منسف على جاج ما بينفع
بدون روز ما بعرف اذا بينفع اصلا هي تلقب
بملكه بملكه الكيتو لتقديمها وصفات مختلفه
تناسب جميع الاذواق مع الحفاظ على كونها
صحيه
ومنخفضه النشويات الشافه السعوديه مرام
الشريف هي احدى اشهر الطهى المتخصصه
بالاكل الصحي اخر ابداعات الشيف مرام كبسه
كيتو تقدمها من في مؤتمر حايل لطب نمط
الحياه تخيلوا اذا كبسه من دون رز او ارز
قليل
لازم ندوق عشان نعرف بس على كل حال الشيخ
مرام مشاهدينا حاصله على دكتوراه فخريه
بفنون الطهي والعديد من الجوائز
بمجالها مجال الطهي اليوم هي مديره ملتقى
الطهاد المحترفين في السعوديه
على تدريب الشباب في المملكه على طه خصوصا
فيما يتعلق بنظام الكيتو تحديدا ملكه
الكيتو
[موسيقى]
المكرمه حاصل على الدكتوره الفخريه فنون
الصهي مدربه محلي ودولي محكمه محلي ودولي
حاصل على الميداليات ذهب في فنون الطهي
خارج المملكه العربيه السعوديه
شاركنا بالكبسه يعني زي كده احنا دائما
انا عموما اطلع الا اسوي اكلي الحجازي
مشاركه بالكبسه الصحيه
من مكه تنضم الينا الشيف مرام مع الشريف
مرام صباح الخير صباح الخير اهلين صباح
النور الشاعر اليمني حسين بوبكر المحضار
يقول احنا قوم رزازه اي نحب الرز اليوم
كبسه من غير رز زين برغل يمكن كان مشيناها
بس رز قليل ومن غير رز شو عم تصير كبسه
لازم تصير كبسه احنا ما نبغى نحرمكم من اي
حاجه طيب ايش رايك شلون تستقيم غير ايوه
كيف غير اليوم غير غير انه احنا استخدمنا
القرنبيط او الزهره بدل الرز
طبعا
بطريقه مختلفه غير عن الطرق التقليديه
اللي احنا متعودين
[موسيقى]
ابدا نفس الكبسه تطبخ يا بدل ما تحطي رز
في قدر الضغط نحط بدالها القرنبيط المبشور
طيب وبعدين
طيب طب انت اول حاجه حتعرف ايش هي الفوائد
الغنيه في القرنبيط اول حاجه انه القرنبيط
مفيد لمرضى السكري حلو وحميه اللوكر
وحميه الكيتو طبعا غنيه بفيتامين كاف
وغنيه بالالياف لقله الكارب الكارب فيها
خمسه جرام
طيب
اتخيل الطعم فيها مضادات اكسده شوف يلا
واحنا واحنا نشوف خلينا نتكلم عن عن
الفوائد
[موسيقى]
طيب
بيشبه البرغل شويه بس هو قرنبيط مبشور
ومطبوخ نفس ما تطبخ الكبسه في قدر الضغط
طب بقيه مكونات الكبسه تفضل تفضل كما هي
ولا ممكن تستعيدي عن قله دجاج مثلا بسلقوا
او شوي
اكثر صحه عادي
لا احنا بعادي بنكشين البصل والتوم مع زيت
الزيتون وبعد كده بنحط شويه الطماطم
والصلصه وبحط الدجاج الين ما يستوي اشيل
الدجاج واحط القرنبيط واضغط في قدره الضغط
لمده خمسه دقائق خليني خليني اسال خليني
اسالك شوف مرام انا راح اجربه وراح اجربه
والله راح اجربه لانه شوقني شكله لكن
خليني اسال لشخص واحد كم قرنبيطك نص كيلو
كيلو كم
100 جرام 100 جرام قرنبيط 2007
كيلو 247
ودجاج
صدر دجاجه الدجاج انت احتياجك صدر الدجاجه
تاخذ 100 تاخذ 150 انت ايش احتياجك طيب
انا طبعا هذا لازم اعرف طولك اعرف وزنك
اعرف انت ايش
الرياضي اللي بتعمله عشان انا اقدر اطلع
لك طولي متر و90 وزني 85
انا فظيع بالنشاط الرياضي ما امارس ولا
نشاط رياضي ما بيتحرك
ما شاء الله كويس الحمد لله
طيب شيف مرام هل يعني دايت الكيكو الكيتو
ممكن انه ينفع مع يعني وصفات اخرى غير
الكبسه ممكن انه
نخرج منها
النشويات وندخل ما هو مفيد عليها
طبعا طبعا
في السعوديه او في دول عربيه اخرى
نعمل مثلا رز البرياني نعمل مثلا عندك
الحلوية بدون انواع الحلويات نعملها معقول
رز الرز بدون رز بالقرنبيط
برضو والرزا الصيني كل انواع الرز نسويها
بالقرنبيط
اللي جنب الكبسه شنو هي لازم اسهل
راح انصدم كيكه الكوسه لا
لا
مقاديرها سريعا هذه كيكه الكوسه جدا مفيده
لمرضى السكر وللاطفال المصابين بمرض السكر
مقاديرها
وانتو عارفين فوائد الكوسا مقاديرها جدا
بسيطه اربع حبات بيض كاسه وثلاثه ارباع
دقيق منخول دقيق بر وحاطه واحده ملعقه
كبيره بيكنج باودر وفانيليا وبعد كده حاطه
كوب ونص كوسه قبل ما
اسالك قبل ما ننهي يعني الكيك عاده او
الكعكه بتكون حلوه والكوسا يعني خضار
يستخدم في الطبيخ الموالح مش في الحلو كيف
جمعتي بين الاثنين وباختصار لو سمحت
ايوه لانه احنا حاطين معاها كمان قرفه
وسكر بني
طعمها مره خرافي ترى لازم تجربيها لذيذه
انا كل ما اسويها ترى العالم بتستغرب انه
انا بستخدم كوسه في الكيك فلما ياكلوها
بصراحه مره ينصدموا طبعا يعني لازم احنا
يا اما نيجي لعندك تستضيفينا او انت
تتفضلي تشرفينا هون المعمل موجود
يسلم قلبك شكرا جزيلا لك تعالوا
شكرا طبعا طبعا تشرفوني اي وقت ان شاء
الله باذن الله شكرا رامز والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات